[Music]
building a butter smooth UI is extremely
important in the world of native apps
it only takes a small amount of jank for
people to think your app sucks that's
why one of my favorite things about
flutter is how beautifully it renders
the animations we can use the built-in
profiler to see that we easily achieve
60 frames per second even for this
complex rotating radio menu in today's
video you'll learn all about flutter
animations by building this menu from
scratch if you're new here like and
subscribe and you can find the full
source code on fire ship IL before we
get started I have a confession to make
in college I failed trigonometry I
vividly remember scoring zero out of 100
points on the midterm and I probably
didn't even take the final and that's
not good because we need to use
trigonometry in this video to determine
where to place the different elements on
the menu if we take a closer look at
this menu we actually have ten different
buttons stacked on top of each other
the open and close buttons stay in the
middle and then they scale up and down
depending on whether or not the menu is
opened or closed when opened all of the
outer buttons will be translated or
moved to a specific bearing from the
center point this is where trig comes
into play because we need to calculate a
specific XY coordinate based on an angle
from the center but don't worry too much
about that it's actually a very easy
calculation and this entire demo only
takes about 150 lines of code which is
pretty crazy and as a final touch will
also add a rotation to the entire stack
of buttons so that way it rotates
clockwise when opening and
counterclockwise when closing to get
started you'll need to have a flutter
app and then I also have vector math
installed and optionally fun awesome for
some better icons the material then if
we go into our main dart file you can
see that I'm importing dart math and
then I'm importing radians from vector
math and it's important to do the import
like this because it has some
conflicting classes with flutter now
we'll go down here to our material app
and we'll just add a scaffold and for
this demo we'll just have the menu fill
up the entire screen and for that we can
use a sized box and have it expand to
fill out the entire viewport and then
the child for that box will be our
custom radial menu widget when working
with animations the first thing you
usually start with is a stateful widget
the only thing this widget is concerned
with is defining the animation
controller which itself controls the
duration of the animation as well as the
controls to tell it to play in forward
or in Reverse what it doesn't control is
the actual animation properties or the
UI Oh
that are being animated the first thing
we'll do is add a mix into this class
called the single ticker provider state
mix in this will put the widget and
ticker mode which makes animations
possible the next thing we'll do is
declare our animation controller and
then we'll actually define it inside of
the annette lifecycle hook the most
important aspect of the animation
controller is the duration at the end of
the video we'll stagger animations which
will all be relative to the duration
that we define here so in this case the
total duration of the animation is 900
milliseconds we also have to pass the
this context to vsync which is just a
piece of boilerplate for animation
controllers in order to achieve 60
frames per second this animation
controller will take every 16
milliseconds I haven't commented out
here but you could add a listener to
this controller and then set the state
every time it takes but we'll be using
an animated builder in the next step
which makes this part unnecessary now
we'll define the build method for this
widget and you'll see it returns a
radial animation widget which will
define next just notice how it takes the
animation controller as a property to
its constructor we'll be using the same
controller to orchestrate multiple
different animations at the same time
all of the animation logic will be
handled by this radial animation widget
in order for it to take the animation
controller as an input property we add
it to the constructor here and then call
super from there we'll define the build
method and it will start with an
animated builder an animated builder
takes two main arguments the first one
is just the animation controller and the
second one is a function to build the UI
so basically every time the animation
controller ticks it will run this
builder function to rebuild all your
widgets we can control the state of this
animation bolt in the stateless widget
or in the stateful widget above because
this is a menu I want to make these
methods a little more clear so I'm
defining my own custom @ that's called
open and closed open we'll run the
animation and forward and then close
we'll run the animation in Reverse now
we can go up to our builder function and
the first thing I'm going to define is a
stack because remember all the buttons
are just stacked on top of each other in
the children array I'll go ahead and add
two floating action buttons and because
we're working with a stack only the last
button should be visible that means you
want the button that will open the menu
initially to be the last item in the
stack if we open this on a device we
should see our blue open menu button and
if we take that out of the stack then
we'll see the close button that takes
care of the initial setup now let's
build the first animation that toggles
open and close button for that we're
going to zoom out a bit and go to the
top of our radial animation button and
first define a property called scale
that is typed to an animation of a
number then we'll define scale as a
tween a tween is one of those words that
always makes me nervous when I see it
however they're actually very simple and
they just translate to in between so you
give it a starting value and an ending
value and it will calculate everything
in between in this case we're animating
the scale of an element and by giving it
a starting point of 1.5 it will be one
hundred and fifty percent of its normal
size and then at the end of the
animation it will be zero percent or
invisible the next thing we need to do
is bind this tween to our actual
animation controller that gives it an
actual duration to know how to calculate
the in-between values you could just
pass then the animation controller
directly here but more often than not
you'll use a curved animation to make
your animations a little more exciting
I'm using fast out slow in but there's a
lot of different curves you can
experiment with here the last piece of
this puzzle is determining where to
apply this animation in the widget tree
the scale animation is only going to
apply to our open and close buttons in
the middle flutter has this super useful
thing called a transform widget and it
has a few static methods to rotate scale
and translate a child widget but it can
also be used for super complex
perspective based 3d animations so
notice here how we've wrapped our
floating action button in the transform
scale and then for the scale argument
we're passing at the scale value from
the tween animation so that means every
animation tick or every 16 milliseconds
it will update the scale value of this
element when it's animating now we'll go
ahead and wrap the other button and
transform scale as well but you'll
notice right now they're both using the
same animation so they'll be doing the
same thing at the same time we could
write an entirely different animation
for each button but we can also be kind
of clever here and instead just subtract
one from the scale value which will give
us the opposite animation for the
closing button always see if you can be
clever first before writing a bunch of
extra code that completes the first
animation if we open it up on a device
we should see the button scaling in and
out when clicked the next challenge is
to create a whole bunch of buttons that
pop out of the middle when the menu is
activated we'll go back up to the
constructor and add another animation
that's very similar to our scale
animation this time we'll go ahead and
call it translation we'll give it a
starting value of zero and an ending
you have 100 then we'll defined a curved
animation and then again make sure to
experiment with the different curves you
have a whole bunch of different options
here now we definitely don't want to
hard-code a bunch of floating action
buttons one by one
instead I'm writing a method called
build button which will take an angle as
an argument which is in degrees and it
will also take an optional color and
icon this is the part where a little bit
of trigonometry is going to help us
write very concise code what we want to
do is translate each individual button
at a specific angle from the center
point of this menu this needs to be done
in radians and not degrees but degrees
are a lot easier to work with if you're
a human being because it's easy to
reason about a circle when you think of
it in 360 degrees so the first thing
we'll do is convert that angle argument
to radians then we'll define a transform
widget and that allows us to actually
pass in a transformation matrix this is
really cool because you can chain
together different transformations by
using darts double dot notation we're
not going to do this today but in theory
we could also chain together a scale and
a rotation if we wanted to in this demo
we're only concerned about the
translation but we need to calculate the
translation based on the X Y value from
the center point of the circle we do
that by taking the current translation
value and then multiplying it by the
cosine of the radians and will give us
the x value and then to get the Y value
we just take the sign of the radians and
even as they failed trigonometry student
I think I understand this and that's all
it takes to calculate that translation
the only other thing we have to do here
is add a child widget which will just be
a floating action button that will take
our icon and background-color arguments
now we can come back up to the widget
tree to our stack and just call this
button for every item that we want to
add to the menu we'll put the first
button at zero degrees the next one at
45 the next one at 90 and so on if you
open up the app you should have an
effect that looks like this at this
point the buttons are going in and out
but there's no rotation going on yet
what I want to show you is how to rotate
the entire widget stack but do it in a
way that's offset from the main
animation timeline this is what you
would call a staggered animation first
we'll set up another number tween and
then we'll start at 0 and rotate around
the entire circle to 360 degrees we can
make this staggered by going into the
curved animation and then instead of
providing a curve will provide an
interval this will tell the animation to
start executing at a certain point in
the animation timeline with the first
value being 0 that means the
we'll start right away but the second
value is 0.7 which means it will end at
70 percent into the animation itself in
other words the rotation animation will
happen faster than the rest of the
animation timeline and now the interval
itself will take the actual curve
argument so that takes care of the
animation now let's come down to the
widget tree and then we'll wrap the
entire stack in the transform rotate
method now the stack will become the
child of this widget and then we'll set
the angle value to the rotation value
the angle is also based on radians so
you'll want to do that conversion there
if you're looking to do one full circle
with 360 degrees now open up the demo on
a device and you should have the super
smooth 60 frame per second animation and
if you don't believe me flutter has a
built-in profiler so just run flutter
run flag profile and you should see that
you have plenty room to spare for even
more animation and UI painting I'm gonna
go ahead and wrap things up there if you
have any UI elements from popular mobile
apps that you might want to see clone on
this channel let me know in the comments
and if this video helped you please like
and subscribe thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon
[Music]